[Applause]
up and at it early arriving for day one
of liz truss's new government and for
now at least it's all smiles how are we
gonna find support for ukraine and
support for energy bills but urgent
questions to answer
for those who've made it back into
cabinet little time to pause are you
late
no i've got another meeting all too
aware of the speed at which they've got
to act
their first cabinet meeting lasts in an
hour this a massive entry for ministers
with little or no experience at the very
top the longest serving cabinet minister
in this room is liz truss where's your
positive living plan prime
minister from chair in her first cabinet
to her first pmqs
just one subject dominant i as prime
minister will take immediate action to
help people with the cost of their
energy bills and i will be making an
announcement
to this house on that tomorrow
and giving people certainty
agreement on both sides of the house
tomorrow's energy package couldn't come
sooner but clear splits on how it should
be funded when she said in her
leadership campaign that she was against
windfall taxes
did she mean it yeah
i am against a windfall tax i believe it
is the wrong thing to be
to be putting
companies off investing in the united
kingdom just when we need to be growing
the economy
he doesn't agree this the big divide
labour want energy companies to use
excess profits to help pay the nation's
energy bills liz trust would rather in
time put it on the taxpayer
this a pm not prepared to pull any
punches happy to set out clear
ideological divisions on economic policy
this country will not be able to tax its
way to growth
the way the way we will grow our economy
is by attracting investment keeping
taxes low delivering the reforms to
build projects quicker the language of
her leadership bid carried into her
government campaign pledges turned into
prime ministerial promises i'm on the
side of people who work hard and do the
right thing
that is why we will reverse the national
insurance increase and that is why we
will keep corporation tax low because
ultimately we want investment right
across our country that is what i will
deliver as prime minister a pm who
prefers to borrow than tax for public
spending the prime minister claims to be
breaking orthodoxy but the reality is
she's reheating george osborne's failed
corporation tax plan
protecting oil and gas profits and
forcing working people to pay the bill
the face at the top may change but the
story remains the same
there is nothing new about the tory
fantasy of trickle-down economics
can't she see
there's nothing new about the tory prime
minister who when asked who pays
says it's you
the working people of britain
well there's nothing new about a labour
leader who is calling for more tax rises
it's the same old same old tax and spend
a new prime minister in a very different
pm cues as the rhetorical flourish of
boris johnson gave way to the more
workmanlike delivery of pm trust
spirited clashes on character and
conduct replaced with more ideological
splits over the direction of economic
policy the two leaders retrenching to
more familiar dividing lines labor
wanting to tax big business to fund
spending the conservatives wanting to
protect it i believe it is the wrong
thing but out of the commons chamber and
in this cafe in sutton coldfield a safe
tourist seat tour remembers here pleased
with what they saw
i think actually the approach that liz
is taking
is the right one we've got a pragmatic
conservative approach to tackling the
crisis in the issues that we're
currently facing and it's very
reassuring that there is a plan
tor remembers the target of her summer
campaign now the audience she needs to
win is the nation sharon voted
conservative in 2019
but right now she's not convinced i
don't think we're in a position really
where we can borrow any more money
i think for the general voter we just
don't understand why these big companies
are not being
sort of looked at and investigated more
and made to pay really for the billions
of pounds profit that they're making
and it's views like that they'll need to
listen to in here liz trust telling mps
this evening the election starts now
if that's the case the days ahead really
are critical beth rigby sky news
westminster